[Applaudissements]
bienvenue salut chaleureux à respecter
en train de faire un spécial comme tous
les jours je prépare ma chronique boulot
boulot là c'est toi et moi j'ai marois
j'ai appris que tu avais essayé de te
débarrasser de moi en prévenant les
américains qu'ils avaient copié c'est
bien possible oui mais j'ai une mauvaise
nouvelle pour toi si elle est là nunavut
remplacer il a même déjà trouvé de
remplaçant benoît du mak d'énergie de 12
1 puisque tu veux jouer à ça sache que
dans salut les terriens jean n'impriment
bien bonne cyril a tenté de remplacer
par un imam
qu'est ce que c'est que ces salamalecs
alors quand vous le groupe canal+ a
acheté des actifs qu'ils ont aidé 8 vais
pas essayer de devenir chroniqueur chez
hanouna tu aurais tu es bon pas près
d'être world je n'ai pas vu venir celle
là c'est un coup dur je pense qu'on
ferait mieux de s'allier bertrand on
n'oublie jamais rien on lit avec
baudelaire ou non hélène ségara cyril
hanouna
j'ai appris que vous faisiez une
excellente annonce à 20h30 est ce que je
pourrais être mis au parfum
écoutez c'est une très bonne nouvelle
bertrand j'ai l'impression qu'on va
l'éliminer plus tôt que prévu cela
j'ai décidé en accord avec des 8es avec
le gouvernement
de postuler
et de me présenter
à la présidence de france télévisions et
voilà qui arrange les affaires allaient
à notre succès combal en plus directeur
de campagne
et là tu vas sûrement me demander
pourquoi c'est un range nos affaires
pourquoi ça rentre nous affaire d
affront que j'étais expliqué regarde ça
sahnoun à ça c'est toi ça c'est moi on
est trois sur le plateau sauf que si on
se met à 2 pour le virer à france télé %
+2 son plateau j'aime ça fectivement
combal j'y crois encore on est vivant
donc on est fort ce bois de l'air non la
fabia en revanche c'est agir est pas
trop lui dérouler le tapis rouge dans
l'émission un tri ont fait pas j'ai
pensé à tout
des images compromettantes j'ai ce qu'il
faut rendez-vous à 19h40
je pense que vous serez pas d'issue
[Musique]
bon on fait le point sur le soutien
d'anna pour france télé écoute ça se
passe pas mal à ça bouge beaucoup je
peux confirmer déjà sophie davant text
ainsi que louis la brocante qui ont pas
mal pas mal qu en est-il de georges
pernoud georges pernoud toujours
injoignable donc on est en train de
faire chier des bulles règne chez paou
forme et en ça mais ça bouge sur les
réseaux le jeune pour fleur pellerin le
futur président de france télé devra
enrayer le vieillissement continue
l'audience ça sent bon le départ de nina
et tu sais quoi
ça c'est bon pour nous mais c'est
surtout bon pour le moral baudelaire non
la compagnie créole bat la campagne se
passe bien le sabotage de tlt roule
aussi que demander de plus peut-être une
est devenu d'extérieur eh bien nous
l'avons
[Applaudissements]
toujours préférer l'original à l'appel
[Musique]
alors comment ça va tu vas bien vous
avez bonne mine tu vas mines
l'opération se déroule à merveille
nouvel allié christophe dechavanne
invité des grandes gueules ce midi qui a
balancé ça sur un oumar sylla nous a
fait à peu près trois fois moins
d'audience que tf1 c'est un fait vim
dans les dents dupas qui est un hymne à
la campagne on en est en jeu c'est le
directeur énorme succès on est de plus
en plus rejoint notamment par la
ministre de la culture fleur pellerin
elle a déclaré aujourd'hui qu'elle veut
un président audacieux qui soit en phase
avec son époque suils cyril elle a
également dit que l'audiovisuel public
doit s'adresser aux jeunes s'ils série
la luna elles vont encore plus loin il
dit qu'il faut faire mieux avec moi ça
niveau budget ici connais un pass n'est
qu'à voir comment tourner la série du
méthode avec hanouna président pour
trois tickets resto tu as une saison de
plus belle la vie saveurs ça fait penser
depuis je traite mes guêtres à
l'assemblée nationale comme le petit
journal quoi bref depuis que je traite
mes guêtres à l'assemblée nationale j'ai
le bras long on a un nouveau soutien et
pas des moindres et on en vient à cette
information à présent alors que camille
combal et bertrand chamerois continuent
leur course pour prendre la place de
cyril hanouna françois hollande lors
affiché publiquement son soutien
je vous propose d'écouter le président
de la république soyez conscients de ce
rôle majeur que vous jouez il faut une
part de patience il faut contrôler son
impatience
et puis il faut aussi de la persévérance
[Musique]
trente six ans sur d8 l'âge moyen 58 ans
sur france 2 soixante ans sur france ô
et 61 points 500 france 3 où sont les
jeunes les jeunes sont aujourd'hui sur
le numérique d'abord mais ce que je suis
très méfiant et vous l'avez laissé
partir t'inquiète pas maitena il
pourrait revenir plus vite que prévu tu
crois que c'est fini jamais c'est juste
une pause un répit baudelaire non céline
dion et garou et dis moi moi est ce que
tu as écouté europe 1 jean-marc
morandini
non eh ben tu devrais rien j'ai été
contacté par deux chroniqueurs et pas
des poires nom de chez ces gens pour
travailler avec moi tiens fait plusieurs
je ne vous le dirais que barbey non je
parle à [ __ ] la merde avec leurs
besoins non non deux hommes ça fait des
semaines
c'est un sétois non je te jure que c'est
pas moi c'est pas toi alors c'est quoi
ça je peux m'expliquer quèsaco ça n'a
rien à voir c'était pour envoyer un
petit journal que qui joue en revanche
toi tu pourrais peut-être m'expliquer ce
que tu quittais avec ça dans ton sac à
main ça n'a absolument rien à voir je
suis simplement que l'accueil j'aime les
jeux je suis très famille donc voilà
c'est la logique c'est exceptionnel mais
je comprends pas je n'arrive pas à
m'expliquer ce qui poussera chroniqueur
tpp à vouloir quitter le navire et
rejoindre dechavanne
je sais pas peut-être le fait qu'elle
nous est insupportable avec tout le
monde qui nous paie comme des chèvres et
que plus personne paul sackey ok c'est
toi non c'est pas mentir il se tourne
c'est pas moi c'est toi ou françois
virot non mais non dechavanne a dit que
c'était un chroniqueur qui pèse mais un
oui non roger petit fils à bruno roger
petit celle du coucou c'est nous oui on
tapait le rapport à l'interview que tu
as donné à morandini vendredi
voilà on aimerait quelques explications
bakool
[Applaudissements]